oh yeah and I like this motif is you
could just like something every oh
that's cool oh that's so cool and it
starts like from the button that you
clicked on mmm good morning guys from
the car with Isaac corners warden
is that really your voice you uh big boy
boys all right but we just got back from
Isaac's CRT lenses I doctor appointment
so Isaac's been on this treatment for
how long has it been
policy here yeah like I think a year and
treatment what it is they're like these
special lenses that Isaac wears when he
goes to sleep and this allows him to
have clearer vision throughout the day
so he doesn't have to wear these lenses
throughout the day and so that's why you
don't see Isaac with glasses anymore
reason why we switched over to these
lenses was because Isaac wanted to wear
contacts he was tired of wearing glasses
yeah oh yeah he did have like a tan line
for the glasses on his nose and I was
missing like the old days where I just
have clear vision wake up clear vision
they still have clear vision one of our
dentists told that mm-hmm yeah Isaac's
dentists actually fronted up during his
checkup he was like oh yeah my daughter
she wears these lenses and it's kind of
like a retainer for your eyeballs
because she just only why's him when she
goes to sleep and then throughout the
whole day she has clear vision and I was
like what is this magic you're talking
about I had never heard about this so
yeah so then we looked into it for Isaac
since you know Casey and I we have lasik
so we don't have to worry about any sort
of like eye corrective this but Isaac
still does so that's why we've been on
this treatment for like a good year now
but yeah we've just finished stepping
out of the office and it was it's been
very interesting because now that we've
been more involved in like the outside
world during this pandemic like the more
and more we see like Oh things are
changing there's new procedures
well because last week we went for our
orthodontist appointment and that's why
I got new aligners and then Isaac got
his plans tightened up I don't know if
you guys have ever seen this but can can
we show them what's inside your mouth
okay yeah I was really interesting
because we recently went to our
orthodontist appointment so Isaac had
his braces tightened up and then I got
new clear aligners those new procedures
and these offices it's just been really
interesting because I'm like oh so we
are now living in a time that we have to
answer like a 10-question thing making
sure that we're not sick making sure we
haven't been in contact with anyone that
has been tested positive for Kovac
making sure that we don't have a fever
so they're trekking our temperature it's
just been really interesting so I'm like
huh oh yeah and obviously like the
biggest thing too is that we have to be
going in and wearing a mask at all times
for our orthodontist appointment for
example luckily they were able to take
us at the same time but they said and
the event that we wouldn't be able to be
in the office at the same time one of us
would have to go wait in the car what
that's crazy there's no longer like a
waiting room for like a lot of these
offices anymore so
oh that's different same thing with here
like with the eye doctor appointment no
waiting room luckily I was able to go in
the room with Isaac but yeah it's just
strange time anyway we're all done here
now
Isaac logged on to my animal crossing
Island around my house I've been talking
about this in the podcast and I'm Jake
Aeneas but here on this channel I will
let you guys know because I I don't hide
from my flaws
I have been practicing escapism through
policy Oh
my mouth is dry sorry this video gets
much likes you'll do I think you guys
care about um coffee I mean if you're
curious sure let me know in the comments
just uh bombard the comments with give
us animal crossing' island tour it no
it's too many words no video gets 1
million then you guys are never gonna
see my I've been meaning to want to do
an animal crossing island tour video
thing but it's just one of those things
where it's like you know you're working
on a blank canvas and you you just want
it to be perfect before anyone gets to
see it and that's kind of where I'm at
right now I'm currently in the middle of
a major remodeling of my Island so it's
a complete mess it is not very nice to
show you guys but then I started
thinking about it I'm like well I've
been playing practically every single
day and almost every single day I play
with my mom so me and my mom visit each
other's islands it was 2 cos yesterday
she actually came to visit our home for
the first time since we moved in she
hadn't like seen it herself so she came
over with my aunt and
cute and then like she brought her
switch to so we were playing next to
each other it was really awesome
Casey even got a photo of us in the
couch so maybe I can make a video for
you guys with my mom and we just go
visit each other's Islands and stuff but
then the other part of me comes in it's
like you guys don't care about animal
crossing so I'm like I don't know you
guys let me know what do you guys want
to see
up next is what isaac or foot or no
doctor it's the doctor and what's gonna
happen you get some shot yeah he's
getting a 7th grade no yo yes oh my shot
I know you know I know used to be so
good with shots when you're little and
then this one day it's one day no one
accidentally scared him and was like
you're about to get shot you're not
scared and then a flip switched in his
brain and then since that day he has
been terrified of shots I have my blood
drawn yeah I mean it's similar a shot
it's actually faster than getting a
blood draw how many shots cat shots it's
seven all right we're going in the
doctor's office I'm terrified okay
shots I guess I'm terrified I'm like
something me here is that you're gonna
be moving on to the seventh grade dude
your whole thing's great just went by
eight like a blink of an eye
it did to be honest that was the
distance learning for you yeah terrible
way it was kind of hard it's easier to
learn when you're old
also I don't know how that's useful
now but the old school they're already
planning on doing either a hybrid broker
or like a fully distance learning
program so you get to decide like
parents get to decide what they want
their kids to do
it's like a hybrid program bead set you
would be going like you have to schedule
and when you would go to school so let's
say like plenn days and thursdays you
would be going in person into the
classroom and getting the senior teacher
and some students they're gonna turn up
at lunch and be at the same
and then all the deaths are going to be
spread apart so it would be like social
distancing and everyone has to wear a
fast a long time I think you're going to
be required to wash your hands at
certain times of the day that's all your
old school but what do you think about
that procedure for where you're in
useful that's going to be your
introduction until a little useful to be
that way I think would be a pretty cool
start teenage
but it also sucks because it's going to
be hard to socialize with other people I
had a different of it at a different
school when I haven't been there yet
we're real tell them to do yeah I can't
even make friends at my first you sure
you'll be able to make friends somehow
but yeah it's nothing going to be
I love a challenge cool experience
though like once you get older and
really guy wants a new school who's the
first semester and through a pendant
at least the plus side is you're still
in contact with your old friends like
some of your old friends yes not only to
friends we actually had a sleepover like
yeah that's before you got my PC they
don't know but oh you guys are so at
least a month ago I got my keyboard and
mouse after that I wanted to get a
monitor so I found a cool really cool
monitor that I could afford
by working hard and after that I don't
wash your car needed some extra money
that make up for the monitor so I think
being an entrepreneur he was like hey
mom what can I do to earn extra money so
I can afford this this monitor because
the keyboard and the mouse he paid for
with his allowance and like the money
that he's been cleaning up over the
years so because of that she was able to
get those two things and he also had
some money for the monitor but he needed
to make up like 30 bucks I think right
like $40 case and I were like okay how
about you wash each of our cars for $15
each car and I'm like we're being really
generous because it's an expensive car
wash but yeah so then we were like cool
well you could wash both of our cars and
then he needed another 10 bucks so I
said like alright for $10 you can switch
out the sheets on our bed so it's like
the bed sheets the pillowcases the duvet
cover which if you guys own a duvet and
you know how big of a pain in the butt
it is to cut change the duvet cover
that's why I was like ok you can do it
for 10 bucks so then he earned the rest
of the money to pay for his monitor and
then for the PC itself us and his dad we
talked and we're like alright it's a lot
of money for this PC so we were like
alright we agreed that this PC will be
an early like very very very early
Christmas present so we told Isaac like
all right you don't expect Christmas
present this year now you've had it for
how long now at least
I think two weeks I loved walking out of
my room having to do something and then
I see a window screen we were like all
right have this computer in your room
but the conditions are gonna be that
every night before he goes to bed he has
to give me the monitor so like unplug
the monitor and then put it outside and
then that way keep just doesn't stay on
them on the computer for the entire
night
so that's kind of the whole computer
situation and we've been good about like
taking breaks and making sure he's not
in front of the screen for too long
because we talked about why that's not a
good thing myopia yeah you don't wanna
mess up your eyes especially after today
you know having your eye doctor
appointment even though the doctor was
like hey make sure you blink a lot and
you like exercise those glands and your
eyes and you walk away from the screen
and you get breaks and all this stuff so
we're trying to be good about that yeah
I've been having a lot of fun we're now
waiting for the moment of truth to get
shots to get his shot because he's
already been saved by the doctor and
turns out he's a very healthy boy yay
celebration time good job didn't it oh
they're here all right my boy you did it
it was literally just two seconds so how
was it
that hurt hurt I got injected in the
needle storm
oh sorry boy
but it's necessary evil because now you
don't have to worry about not being able
to enter seventh grade maybe stop
touching it oh yeah she did say because
you were very tense
I should've massaged like the muscle
around it but if it hurts hurts maybe
let it chill for a little bit you're
gonna be a man oh I want her story
yeah so Isaac got the Tdap vaccine which
is for seventh grade and then he also
got something else I forgot already
because I sign the paper but you know
those like vaccine words are kind of
hard to remember but one that I do
remember that you didn't get for sure is
Gardasil so it's for the HPV vaccine
which is an STI and so Isaac and I just
had a conversation about what that means
and what it protects and like what
happens if you get HPV and all that
stuff so these are important
conversations to have with your kids
people so yeah I mean it's kind of
awkward I guess if you make it awkward
but I think every time I talk to you
about about sex and stuff do you think
it's awkward a little bit yeah how about
when I blog it no no no cuz awkward
stage nice before turning on the camera
is when we had the conversation and then
I asked him on like hey I was like so
you know how we're blogging today do you
think it's okay if like I included in
the blogs
he was like yeah sure no worries like
hey I raised you well my boy I think I'm
doing a pretty good job what do you
think
how are you feeling now cuz we've been
waiting for they told us to wait for 15
minutes before we leave just to make
sure you don't have any sort of reaction
to the vaccine but how are you feeling
pretty good yeah it's kind of hard to
stay relaxed right right before they
give it to you
yeah it's like that moment of tension
where you're like loads about to fly
poke me oh yeah so we have five more
minutes left waiting out this vaccine
and then once we leave we're gonna head
back home and and you guys are gonna get
to see Isaac's new computer that he's
been obsessed with for the last few days
and the monitor he's been loving so look
forward to that in a few seconds see you
then
all right we're home now back from the
doctors KC is actually grocery shopping
that's why you haven't seen him in the
video I promised you I would show you
guys Isaac's computer look at that
look at you you full on PC er yeah so
give us the tour oh you should turn this
on so I bought this and this hmm hmm hmm
that's kind of cool it's like a really
light smaller for a small hand I
should've got the big one because my
hand is right and this is my mouse Perry
didn't really talk about it but I got a
mouse pack for this one and my keyboard
mm-hmm pretty nice yeah and look how
coolest thing curves - yeah hmm HDMI em
in and dpi cool so you learned all those
computer computer terminology thingies
what it means
yeah or like kind of look check this out
all right so that's the crack that Isaac
was talking about earlier
wait did this get worse no and they're
gonna be sending a new glass there's a
hole oh you got crack here they have to
you can't just leave it all broken so
we're gonna be getting that fixed for
sure it's cyber PowerPC it's pre built
just look on Amazon for cipher power P
PC there you go
do you think you'll ever want to build
your own PC sometimes no I want to do
stuff to my PC hey I wish they built it
oh you can pop it off yeah oh man what
those are the fans yeah it would be
careful don't touch it cool though you
can see everything ms:i
GeForce GTX
what does all that mean this is the
graphics card in the g-force yes there
is a inter is to before six fans old
together that at seven Wow Intel's
actually pretty good CPU and then this
says Windows 10 nice do my favorite
color
yeah yeah I like that color
oh really I like blue and red nice I
could change this
oh that's cool oh yeah by the way I
absolutely love this keyboard because of
the clicks like as soon as Isaac got it
I was like oh my god this is so
satisfying oh yeah and I like this mochi
is you could just it lights up in Eureka
oh that's cool oh that's so cool and it
starts like from the button that you
clicked on mmm then this one to like
cool and say this is the biggest mouse
pad I've ever seen in my life
it's like why is it so big and then I'm
trying to get LEDs mm-hmm so it's gonna
go like in the edge yeah and I like how
other gamers do it yeah actually my
friend has LEDs what else do you wanna
do do you have any plans for like that
big ol white space hopefully in the
future I get LEDs for my bed oh under
the bed that'd be cool
oh yeah and eventually we have to put up
your hook but he's gonna we already
bought the hook but we have to put it up
right there and then have its backpack
right yeah and then this is where I will
also be doing homework mm-hmm instead of
that little Chromebook so before when I
had all my old I listed everything I
wanted except for I recently added added
the LEDs I had it a bunch of bookmarks
for the mouse the keyboard and mouse
mm-hmm mouse pad I got Allison mm-hmm um
the monitor PC mm-hmm all that stuff in
the oculus there so it's been like a
momentous occasion every time Isaac buys
one of the things that are on his
bookmarked list and then we all get
together and we all like push the button
to delete yeah that's pretty cool now I
get it we could gather around and delete
it from here and so
oh yeah true cuz it's been the
Chromebook recently it's been so cute
because it's like a little like family
like celebration kind of thing and we're
all like three two one delete and I look
so happy like yeah I finally got the
thing that I had like wish for you know
that's kind of like the vision board
thing that you're doing so people do
these things that where it's like a
vision board and then they set up like
still they'll find the photo of the
exact house that they want and then
they'll print it out and they'll put it
on this board or like the exact drop but
they want or whatever it is things that
people want to achieve like their goals
and then they place it up on this board
and they call it a vision board and then
like that's like you're putting out the
intention out in the universe that
that's what you want
and that's exactly what you've been
doing with your bookmarks I can imagine
you have a picture of the house oh my
baby
you earned this you've been very
responsible with your break may I have
my maybe glasses yeah for the blue light
good job alright I'll leave you to it
then we're all done out your arms still
hurting Lucy it actually doesn't anymore
[Music]